madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
tout d'abord
je voudrais par quelques mots à porter
le soutien du groupe démocrate à notre
collègue Carlos Martens bilongo
et je m'associe totalement à tous ceux
qui pensent qu'on ne peut accepter de
telles propose
et qui je crois en écho à ce que nous a
dit tout à l'heure madame la Présidente
nous pensons au groupe démocrate que
cette violence qui monte tous les jours
un peu plus dans notre société doit être
combattu coûte que coûte et que notre
rôle centrale nous représentant de tous
les Français doit être bien au contraire
d'apaiser
nous sommes nous sommes là
pour débattre la motion de censure que
le groupe la France insoumise à déposer
mercredi
si tôt le 49-3 décidé par le
gouvernement évidemment nous ne voterons
pas cette motion pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord mes chers collègues parce que
censuré le gouvernement n'a de sens que
si l'on peut constituer une majorité
alternative or jamais vous n'avez
prétendu vouloir atteindre cet objectif
ensuite parce que le gouvernement ayant
déjà engagé sa responsabilité sur la
première partie du projet de loi il est
logique il le fasse sur la seconde
partie en effet dès lors que les
recettes sont adoptées chacun comprendra
la concordance qui doit prévaloir pour
les dépenses c'est une cohérence que
nous devons garantir pour l'équilibre de
nos comptes publics auquel nous sommes
particulièrement attachés également pour
la cohérence de la politique que nous
souhaitons mener pas plus qu'il y a de
logique politique il n'y a de logique
comptable derrière cette notion de
censure dès lors que ces deux prétextes
sont écartés je me tiens un prêt à
discuter en effet l'opportunité de
l'usage à répétition de l'article en 93
notre Constitution
pour tout parlementaire ce n'est pas une
satisfaction j'en conviens parfaitement
mais là encore je dis à nos collègues de
la France insoumise de la nupesse que
nous en serions pas là si vous n'aviez
pas annoncé dès le mois de septembre que
vous ne voteriez pas le budget de la
nation il est ensuite facile de jeter la
responsabilité sur le gouvernement de
l'usage du 49-3 comment on peut se poser
à la fois comme défenseur du
parlementarisme et en même temps
annoncer qu'on va s'exonérer de son rôle
de législateur pour s'entretenir une
posture une posture politique stérile
comment peut-on se prétendre à la fois
majorité alternative d'un gouvernement
introuvable et se défausser de la
responsabilité qui est celle de tout
parlementaire de veiller au bon usage
des deniers publics comment on peut se
réclamer
un corps et un cri des débats et des
échanges de l'écoute et de la
concertation et dans le même temps
refuser à priori de voter un budget pour
son pays il faudra bien jour que vous
sortiez de vos propres incohérences le
vernis commence à craquer et on se rend
bien compte que ces motions censurent à
répétition
n'ont en fait notre but que de donner
des tribunes certes avec talons parfois
aux orateurs de la nupesse qui surjoue
sans arrêt soi-disant déni de démocratie
chers collègues plutôt que faire la
révolution je vous propose de
réconcilier les Français
on ne peut pas faire comme si le cadre
budgétaire n'existait pas vous avez
d'ailleurs remarqué que nous avons aussi
voté le budget de certaines missions
pourtant modifier par amendement dès
lors que celle-ci restait dans le cadre
qui nous semblait confort à l'équilibre
global ce fut le cas des missions
justice défense aux cultures la semaine
dernière
on ne peut accepter des dérapages de
l'ampleur de ceux que vous avez provoqué
sur le budget la mission écologie lundi
dernier en privant par un effet de vases
communicants nos concitoyens du net qui
leur permet de faire face à la hausse
des prix de l'énergie il n'est pas
raisonnable d'accroître tes dépenses de
15 milliards d'euros et de compromettre
la cohérence d'un budget qui est le gage
de notre crédibilité vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires
le budget qui nous est proposé est en
premier lieu un budget qui vise à
protéger nos concitoyens en témoigne la
hausse de 3 milliards d'euros de la
mission défense de 1,4 milliards d'euros
de la mission sécurité s'agissant
notamment des moyens de la sécurité
civile ou plus emblématiquement encore
la hausse de 8% des crédits de la
mission justice pour la troisième année
consécutive ce budget donne aussi la
priorité à la jeunesse avec une
amplification de la revalorisation des
personnels enseignants près d'un
milliard d'euros devraient ainsi
permettre d'augmenter les salaires du
personnel
enseignants de 10% en moyenne à compter
de la rentrée 2023
l'effort en faveur de notre jeunesse ne
s'arrête pas la simple revalorisation du
salaire des enseignants nous devons
continuer à investir pour améliorer plus
encore des techniques éducatives ce
budget propose ainsi abonder de nouveaux
Fonds d'innovation pédagogique de 300
millions d'euros d'ici 2025 mes chers
collègues il est tout à fait possible de
faire progresser des idées et des
mesures de faire bouger les lignes quand
même combien même elle ne serait pas
dans le texte d'origine présenté par le
gouvernement cela nécessite de notre
part à tous adopter une attitude ouverte
et responsable on peut toujours discuter
on peut toujours discuter des priorités
l'action publique mais il faut aussi
être capable de saluer de soutenir ce
qui le mérite par définition la
démocratie appelle à faire des compromis
le travail parlementaire a plus forte
raison nécessite de s'entendre sur des
grands enjeux qui sont devant nous nous
l'avons démontré à plusieurs reprises y
compris lors de cette discussion
budgétaire sur l'épargne de précaution
sur le prolongement du crédit d'impôt
haute valeur environnementale la hausse
du plafond l'exonération 75% des droits
de mutation est gratuit pour faciliter
la transmission des exploitations
agricoles les députés démocrates ont
réussi à faire avancer de nombreux
sujets en seconde partie je pense ici au
moyen supplémentaires alloué au soutien
des professionnels accompagnant les
victimes mineures de violences sexuelles
et d'inceste à la liberté supplémentaire
donnée aux élus locaux dans la
répartition des recettes de la taxe
d'aménagement avec notre collègue Stella
Dupont et les autres groupes de la
majorité nous sommes fiers d'avoir pu
porter la revalorisation de 10% des
aesh à compter de la rentrée 2023 ainsi
que le maintien des crédits à louer à
l’hébergement d'urgence nous avons su
avancer ensemble avec les autres groupes
politiques et le gouvernement sur des
sujets centraux comme la hausse
historail historique de 320 millions de
la DGF la création d'un filet de
sécurité pour les collectivités
confrontées à de fortes hausses du prix
de l'énergie ou encore le maintien du
schéma d'emploi de l'ONF je voudrais
d'ailleurs
dire ici madame la Première ministre que
nous sommes très vigilants sur le
respect des engagements par le
gouvernement sur le financement de
l'Institut Paul-Émile Victor sujet qui
fait consensus sur quasiment tous les
bancs de cette assemblée voyez mes chers
collègues oui nous pouvons nous
retrouver largement sur de nombreux
sujets à la condition de travailler
collectivement pour trouver le juste
équilibre cela empêche en Rial des bas
cela n'efface pas les différences de nos
familles politiques qui sont le reflet
de la diversité de nos opinions dans
notre pays je crois profondément qu'on
peut avoir qu'on ne peut avoir raison
tout seul ni vous ni nous le sens du
message envoyé par les Français lors des
élections législatives les juin dernier
le groupe démocrate y est
particulièrement attentif nous devons
plus que jamais nous efforcer de
poursuivre cette démarche je vais citer
qu'un exemple parmi d'autres on évoque
beaucoup ces derniers jours la question
du partage de la valeur pour laquelle de
vrais progrès ont été fait ces dernières
années il reste pourtant des choses à
faire et c'est là un sujet essentiel
dans l'impact peut être fort dans notre
société tout simplement parce qu'il est
juste nous concitoyens y sont sensibles
et cela doit être pour nous une
préoccupation de chaque instant nous
devons progresser sur ce point sans
casser la dynamique d'entreprise dans
une économie ouverte comme la nôtre nous
avons fait la démonstration que nous
étions capables de nous retrouver
largement sur des sujets de cette nature
et que nous gagnerions à travailler
ensemble le prochain texte financier le
collectif budgétaire sera d'ailleurs une
opportunité pour avancer ensemble au
service de nos concitoyens il contient
des éléments importants le chèque
énergie de 100 à 200 euros l'indemnité
carburant pour les citoyens qui
utilisent le plus leur voiture le
soutien à nos universités aux CROUS pour
aider les étudiants à faire face à des
hausse de les mesures d'indemnisation
pour les agriculteurs victimes de la
crise de cet été le soutien renforcé à
France compétences pour l'apprentissage
nous pouvons être capable de nous
entendre pour soutenir nos concitoyens
votez un tel texte mes chers collègues
ne ferait pas de vous des membres d'une
majorité élargie ce serait simplement
l'usage normal d'un mandat de
parlementaire qui tout en gardant ses
convictions et d'abord d'être au service
des citoyens dans un moment aussi dur
que celui que notre pays traverse je
vous remercie je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]